the first thing about video games is
that their universe is incomplete you're
in a game stupid game where you are
shooting fighting on the Main Street of
a small town let us say and in the back
you see forest with trees but it's not
part of the game that you can approach
those trees and see them in detail it's
part of the game that you cannot go
there so the programmer say why lose
time on that program
let's leave it open quantum physics does
it not have the same lesson when God was
programming the universe he said people
are too stupid to reach beyond the atom
so why should I bother their programming
he lived it undetermined and we were a
little bit too bright for God and we as
you say in English caught god with his
pants down as it
were